does convenience store delivery of 30
dollar ticket makes sense when the
delivery cost is 50 of the order and are
people not going to walk downstairs and
just buy it themselves when they get
home
yeah i mean that's a great point that
that that is going to be the test of
time is for for these guys is that the
percentage that they're spending
on the basket on the delivery cost and
in certain markets you're going to have
higher spend and higher cost right and
then certain other markets i think in
turkey the labor is much cheaper so you
know the the the delivery cost is a
percentage of the aov the average order
basket is um
is uh
you know it's lower so
um
so that's kind of it's all about the
ratio there um
and so what the opportunity that these
guys are are seeing is that this this
could eat you know the small to mid
middle tier um
convenience stores and retailers in the
us so obviously that's a 1.1 trillion
dollar town in the u.s
i don't have the figures for global but
um
that's kind of the what they're looking
at and and they think it's a more
sustainable
model because you're you're you know
basically inventorying a store based on
um what people are ordering the most
frequently uh right you're skipping the
cream so you don't have to have as many
skews
instead of
you know grocery store has 30 40 50 000
skews you're talking about what at these
stores like 5 000 or something
uh it can range from so a good tier does
like 1500 gopal is like up to a 5 000
some of the devmos it's acquired we can
talk about that but um yeah devmo got
acquired that's incredible that was a uh
you know very popular company with its
own built-in delivery service that i use
bevmo
here in the bay area and you can put
your order in on their site it has a
certain window is it as
good as like using
instacart good eggs ubereats or
postmates no it's janky but i used it on
the website and it was okay
it wasn't terrible it was kind of like a
1.0 if you know uber and instacarter 3.0
in terms of delivery services like a 1.0
delivery service we pick a window and it
came they were using outsourced drivers
at bethmo when i used it here um over
the summer in the last couple of months
but i had a okay experience
um
it seems to me convenience stores might
be not a great business it's okay maybe
they have a low margin but alcohol is
high margin
so is the play here that you have an
okay business that creates a floor and
then you make your profit on alcohol
like restaurants do
absolutely i mean i think that's why i
would put gopuff as the one of the
winners in the space and i think there's
going to be different winners for each
part of the market and you might have to
segment that by east coast west coast
yeah i mean biggie tupac um but you know
um
yes i do think that the gross margins of
a go puff are much higher because
they've actually gone through the the
difficult work of
acquiring offline retailers
um and they'll go acquire it for like
half time sales and then go raise at a
you know 13x multiple off of that total
revenue base between go puff and bev mo
and that's what you kind of saw here's a
question from our live audience uh
from linkedin's live stream thank you
linkedin for including us in the live
streaming beta uh works really well by
the way bram burgas what unique real
estate conversations conversions or
repurposed plays are you seeing in the
last mile industry retail space
especially in the commissary slash cloud
kitchen space
so what's happening there in terms of
real estate place because those are real
estate businesses more than delivery
businesses correct
you're talking about cloud kitchens
asking about cloud kitchen's common
series yeah specifically
yeah i mean i think the number one
player here is travis conic's cloud
kitchens which is you know basically
buying distressed real estate and
converting it into
you know basically this last mile
infrastructure that is quietly powering
um lots of uh
delivery transactions mostly delivery
although they have like a facade in
front um just so it's not blight in a
neighborhood and it's not looked at as a
you know some tech companies
or whatever yeah they look good there
was one across the street from my office
in the city in san francisco that looks
great
there's some decent technology going on
there i would order from um
starboard and belcampo two really great
brands
uh and when i would order from those
brands which just have incredibly high
quality chicken and beef for starboard
and um bill campbell respectful
respectively
i would go there to pick up and it was
incredibly sophisticated where
they had all the drivers coming in the
drivers could see you know on panels
where their stuff was the food was in
lockers and man they were cranking over
there and if you pick up your stuff on
ubereats it was zero dollars so i was
like i need to get fresh air i want to
go for a walk so i'd walk across the
street and pick up my chicken and come
back and i'd save seven or eight bucks
on the delivery cost and it was the
reason i did it was faster like i don't
want somebody to drive around the corner
of my stuff it would take twice as long
um
but that seemed they seemed to have some
pretty great technology going on cloud
kitchens yeah
they basically had to build it all
themselves from the ground so if you
look at cloud kitchens is really just a
an umbrella uh it's just one business
within an umbrella of a lot of other
companies um there's a company that owns
the real estate there's a company that
owns a tablet that pipes into all the
third-party marketplaces there's a
company that owns these virtual brands
with funny titles that sound like buzz
feed
um articles there's another company that
is cloud kitchens and so it all kind of
accrues back to the
real estate and they're able to generate
you know abnormal returns on the real
estate because they buy them cheap and
they're able to charge very high rents
per square foot that are abnormal
if you're a chef and you're looking to
open a business
you know
in a city what does that cost compared
to opening a delivery business
in i mean for every one restaurant and
storefront you would open as a
restaurateur how many cloud kitchens
could you open and how many cities
i mean yeah five to one ten to one i
don't know i'm taking again you could i
mean so you you need to spend about
fifty to a hundred thousand dollars and
and up front capex just on the kitchen
equipment and then you need then you're
going to spend about
the lease is about you know maybe i need
to i haven't i'm a little rusty on these
numbers but maybe some in the range of
around six thousand dollars plus they
take
you know something around five percent
of your sales um so all in you're
looking at you know 80 90k
and if it costs you 100 you know it
costs you a million dollars to open up a
store yes it's it's about five
five or ten percent probably
five five yeah five cloud kitchens for
every physical restaurant but you can
advertise the cost of that
kitchen equipment
yeah and so you think about it like
if you are a restaurateur and you've got
some amazing brand man and you could
always open three brands i mean that's
the other thing that's amazing about
this i i
heard you're talking on another podcast
about the early days of uber eats and
i guess jason who was running it at the
time said they knew that you know from
the data hey there's no ramen people
keep searching for ramen there's no
ramen store or we're under
uh more under romanized they just said
hey you know to three or four other
kitchens or cloud kitchens you might
want to think about ramen and
you might you may hit a winner there um
so i think that's pretty
extraordinary now
yeah absolutely and that's kind of where
this is all going i think the tech
companies own the demand right doordash
uber instacart they have so much great
data now they need to go they go back to
their retailers and say hey we know that
there's this demand at this hour of the
day for this particular item whether
it's you know
a late night burger or pizza whatever it
is and they figure out if you have the
right ingredients you could go and you
know satisfy this demand on this on our
marketplace and it's bet and it kind of
works for the restaurant because it's
incremental it works for the marketplace
because they get
increasing you know gmv
and you know and the customer gets to
have some product
at the last mile delivered in you know
15 30 minutes that they wanted that that
wasn't there before
when you are trying to grow a startup
fast hiring engineers will slow you down
like nothing else don't i know it so
many companies i invest in are telling
me they can't get their next version out
because they don't have a great engineer
well lemon.io will find you a perfect
candidate in just 48 hours it's a
marketplace of engineers from europe and
they test and interview every developer
to eliminate the risk of a failed
project lemon io is the perfect solution
if you are a technical co-founder and
you need to delegate some of your
important tasks or you have a project
that needs specific technology and you
don't have that skill on your team yet
or you are just growing so fast that you
need to add more developers and get more
done faster they'll match you with a
candidate within 48 hours and if it
doesn't work out they'll replace the
developer right away so here is your cta
the old call to action if you could use
a full time or even part-time developer
to run your projects faster go to lemon
dot io slash twist once again lemon l e
m n dot io slash twist and you'll
receive a fifteen percent discount for
the first four weeks of work with that
amazing developer well done lemon okay
check it out everybody lemon dot io
slash twist